on connaît bien les dangers de la
pollution atmosphérique on sait moins en
revanche que l'air que nous respirons
dans notre maison dans notre appartement
peut aussi être nocifs pour la santé
c'est greenpeace qui le démontrent
aujourd'hui dans une étude l'association
écologiste a mené une enquête dans 58
logements et les conclusions ne sont pas
vraiment rassurante regard dès lors à 14
ce qui dit des rancoeurs
nous sommes chez la comédienne marion
cotillard
il ya six mois cette fervente écolo a
participé à une étude menée entre autres
chez elle par greenpeace sur la
pollution domestique surprise certains
produits sont quotidiens peuvent être
particulièrement dangereux
dans tout ce qui est des cif détergents
et autres tu peux retrouver ce produit
comme chez toi et qui tient un produit à
peu inquiétant ce qu'ils y perdent
chaude les hormones et bien sûr ils vont
jamais marqué contient un produit
cancérigène partout bat pour ça
l'actrice avait pourtant l'impression de
respecter l'environnement et de faire
attention à sa santé en choisissant des
produits verts mais visiblement on n'est
jamais à l'abri
protéger nulle part quand on essaye à
tout prix de se protéger soi-même ou
quoi autre danger les équipements hi fi
ou le téléphone des objets ignifuges et
qui dégage une poussière toxique
même constat pour les aérosols
un aérosol par définition ces petites
particules qui reste dans l'air
plusieurs jours tant pendant plusieurs
jours une fois que sera diffusé un
parfum qui sera diffusé un insecticide
tu vas le respirer tu vas aller donc tu
t'exposes des substances chimiques et ça
c'est vraiment un réflexe que tout le
monde après que plus personne ne remet
en question les sciv maquillage
détergents la plupart de ces produits
contiennent des substances nocives
la seule réponse facile simple qu'on
peut avoir c'est de dire il faut pas il
ne faut pas qu'on mette ces substances
sur le marché on est incapable de les
contrôler en est incapable de savoir où
elles vont se terminer et apparemment
elle termine dans notre corps dont il ne
faut pas les mettre sur le marché un
projet de loi allant dans ce sens sera
discutée demain à la commission
européenne